Man, I really appreciate
you coming out here,
get a chance to see our facility here.
We got pool.
We got ping pongs.
See, we even got like a little
golf simulator over here.
No way. Come on
It's a little golf simulator over here.
Yeah. Yeah.
I need to take some pictures.
Yeah, yeah.
Take them back to the Cardinals.
It's crazy because last year,
my first year here with the team,
was the first year they opened
up this practice facility
and it is unbelievable.
Eat over there food.
Got massage rooms.
You guys sell memberships?
JJ, what's up man?
How are you?
Sorry. I can't give you my right hand.
No. Worries. No worries.
In due time. In due time.
In due time indeed.
I really appreciate you being here.
Glad to be here, man.
So first, I just wanna
start off with family.
Like what was it like
growing up in your household
with all the athletes?
Competitive. Extremely competitive.
Obviously, my two brothers,
both being in the league now.
Which is sick. Just for the record.
Unbelievable.
You just say that like it's...
It's crazy, man.
It's crazy because we
literally used to play
in the front yard.
Obviously me being the oldest,
I used to beat up on
them a bit probably which
I take credit for turning
them into some athletes.
But it was truly competitive.
It was wild.
My parents started us out in
hockey when we were young.
And I truly believe that
one of the reasons...
That’s that Wisconsin thing
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of the reasons we're successful.
So I started skating when
I was three years old.
So when I was three years old,
I was trying to balance myself on ice
on this little itty bitty blade.
And I think that that taught
me some core strengths.
Some ability to handle my body in space.
How to move around,
how to balance,
how to coordinate yourself.
And my brothers and I,
we all played hockey.
That was our number one sport.
Never knew that.
Ya’ll just wanted to hit people.
-I get it. I get it.
-That's it. That's it.
It all makes sense now.
So we were going in the basement.
We'd have these mini sticks
where we'd get on our knees
and we'd play hockey,
and we'd bang around.
The basement walls took a beating.
We broke through some basement walls.
We had to pay for some
dry wall with chores
and things like that.
But always competitive,
always trying to win.
I didn't take it easy on them.
They'd cry for a second and get back up
and get back in the game.
It was always competitive.
I can't imagine having one sibling
being a professional athlete,
but having all three.
Like once you got there,
did you sort of know that
they would make it too?
I knew they would both
make it cause the mindset.
I think that...
We come from a small town in Wisconsin.
We had two Division I
football players ever.
One of them made it to the NFL.
All that did for me was
tell me it was possible.
So I just had to follow a plan,
and then my brothers
could follow that plan.
I knew their drive and how hard they work
and how determined they were.
I knew they'd make it.
You started off at Central Michigan.
Yeah.
Right.
And then you went to Wisconsin.
Yeah.
As a walk on.
How.
I went to Central Michigan as a tight end.
I was on scholarship.
I told my parents,
"School's paid for. Don't worry about it."
Right.
But they ran the spread offense,
and I only played like 10 plays a game.
I was a starter my freshman year,
but I had big dreams. I had big goals.
I didn't wanna play 10 plays a game and...
That wasn't gonna get me into the NFL.
So I transferred to Wisconsin.
I walked on.
I was like, "I'm gonna put
all my eggs in this basket."
And my parents said
they had enough money
for one year of school.
If I didn't get a
scholarship after one year,
then I'd have to figure it out on my own.
So I knew I had to make it work.
And sometimes when your
back's against the wall,
when you don't give yourself
any other option but success,
that's the best way to create success.
And it worked out.
Yeah. You make that sound real easy.
You make it sound real easy,
but that's unbelievably tough.
And then you actually left
Wisconsin after your junior year.
Yeah.
So how do you...
You go with no scholarship
and then you leave early.
Yeah, yeah.
Like what did that teach you
about motivation,
about betting on yourself, basically?
That's exactly what...
It was betting on yourself.
And it was,
if I put myself in a situation
where there was no option but to succeed,
because I literally
would not have been able
to stay going to school.
I literally would not
have been able to advance
if I didn't do that.
So I was watching a film
at 10 o'clock 11 o'clock at night
with the coaches because
I was on the scout team.
They weren't gonna
watch me during the day,
they had starters to watch.
So I was on the scout team,
and we were watching film at night.
I was showing up early for work.
I was with the strength coach.
I was on the scout team.
I was going up against
the number one offensive
line in Wisconsin.
We had like six, All Americans.
Our backup was an All American
by the time he was a senior high.
I was going up against the
best guys in the country.
And I was like, "If I can
play against these guys,
I can play against anybody."
And it was every single day,
like, I'd get my ass kicked.
But then I'd get up and I'd
kick somebody else's ass.
And then once I'd kick
in All American's ass,
I was like, "Maybe I'm an
All American. Hang on."
And then I'd be like,
"Maybe I'm a draft pick." And...
You left to go to the NFL
after your junior year.
Right.
How did that decision come about?
I mean, I'd be lying to
you if I didn't say that
the fact that you get paid
to do the thing you love
wasn't a part of it too.
Like they told me,
you submit your forms to see
if you were gonna get drafted.
Like when you're a junior,
you submit the forms.
And they said that I might
be a late first round
or early second rounder.
So my coaches there were telling me
that I might be a third rounder.
They're trying to get
you to stay in school.
They're trying to get me in school.
That's not all.
Yeah. Yeah.
So I was like, "I know I'm
gonna crush the combine.
I know that my film has been good.
I know I'm gonna interview good."
So I'd bet myself again.
I'd bet myself.
Went to the combine, had
a really good combine.
Ended up getting drafted 11th overall.
And I knew that I would
have an opportunity
to potentially set up my
family for generations to come.
And the risks of not having that happen,
I couldn't take those risks.
That's amazing.
You want me to show you
the facility real quick?
I do. Yeah.
Let's check it out. This
place is incredible.
This place is insane.
Yeah, man.
So it's crazy.
Like it's so nice.
You don't get with so much
use out of it up here.
Everything's big man friendly too.
It's got big chairs.
Exactly.
It's got big couches.
Everything.
Yeah. This is nice.
It's designed pretty well too.
It is.
It has nice features.
Perfect spot.
Yeah. Craziest thing
though, about this facility.
And I still...
I need to ask Sarver why he did it.
There's a hot tub out there, man.
I was wondering why there's
no wall right there.
There's a hot tub...
Look out the road?
There's a real hot tub
that faces the road.
You gotta talk to Sarver about that.
Just put you and D. Bookie
and all the guys out there
and you can just chill in the hot tub.
So at one point,
aside from quarterbacks
or anything like that,
you was the highest earner in the league.
How did you deal...
Not did or do, you deal
with the wealth? Right?
Yeah.
I don't know what your bank account
or account looked like in college,
but I had 151 dollars before I got drafted.
Oh man.
Before I declared.
We went to a bowl game once in college
and one of my teammates,
we were gonna go to a party that night.
And we went to like the foot locker
and he was like,
"You gotta get those Jordans
for the party night."
And I was like, "Those
Jordans are like $300.
Where am I gonna get that?"
And he was like, "You got per diem money."
And I was like, "Yes, I
have $300 of per diem money.
You want me to spend it
all on these Jordans?"
He convinced me. I bought them.
I bought the Jordans. I had no food.
I had to find my food
for the rest of the week.
But I was like, I did it.
So my financials is a lot different now.
And it's...
You're figuring it out as you're going.
and you're putting your own spin on it.
I was always gonna be
conservative of my money
because I want it to last forever.
Beyond me for generations to come.
But I also try and let myself understand
that you should appreciate and enjoy
what you've worked so hard to get.
So I'm fortunate here.
I live in a beautiful
house here, but I also,
at the same time I drive a truck
because I found a way
to get a truck for free.
I don't drive like a crazy fancy car,
I'm very lucky and I'm fortunate,
but I am conscious always
of trying to make sure
that I'm being smart with it
and not getting crazy.
And also setting a good example
for my brothers as well.
Do you remember what
the best piece of advice
you were given as far as financially?
Early on, I always tried to
live off of just endorsements.
I know that there's plenty of...
I'm a defensive lineman,
so there weren't too
many of them early on,
so I wasn't leaving that high off it.
But that is something
that throughout my career,
I've always tried and made sure
that I was bringing enough off the field.
If I didn't want to,
I would never have to touch
the on the field stuff.
So like what advice would you give to a
young guy coming into the league now
that you've been in
the league a long time?
The best advice that I
ever give to young guys is
invest in yourself, in your
body, in your craft right now
that you you will never,
unless you're a absolute genius,
brilliant business mind,
or you have some unbelievable connections,
you will never have an
opportunity to earn as much money
for what we're about to do right now.
Like imagine...
Think about some of the contracts
that are going on right now.
Think about quarterbacks that are making
$200 plus million dollars in the NFL.
You have an opportunity to
set yourself up with wealth
that will last for generations to come.
Don't worry about the lifestyle.
Don't worry about
everything else on the side.
Worry about what can make you,
A, maker team great,
but also B, set yourself up financially.
It's a very difficult thing
because I've been there too.
I was young. I was a young guy.
I know that the lifestyle
is extremely enticing.
I know that there's...
And I'm not saying you
gotta commit to it 24/7,
like you have to be psychotic about it.
But you do kind of gotta
be psychotic about it.
It's always the same.
Keep the main thing, the main thing.
Amen.
Right. And...
You're giving me flashbacks here, man.
Do you remember what the
first thing was you bought?
What was your first big purchase?
I remember my...
The house I bought in Houston.
Closing the house,
took the key, drove to the house,
walked through the front door,
walked through the back door,
jumped in the pool with all my clothes on.
Because I was like, I've never...
I didn't ever think I'd...
I couldn't conceptualize
having my own house.
No greater feeling.
And I was like, "This is mine."
I just jumped in my own
pool. I just jumped...
That was the coolest thing ever for me.
And then being able to buy my mom a car,
being able to buy my parents a house.
There's no feeling like that.
There's no feeling.
People probably see me wouldn't know
that I used to have a
Escalade with 26 inch rims.
Spinning rims.
I had a drop down TV in it
and all that stuff, man.
But you get a chance
to live and you learn.
No doubt.
Yeah.
Dude, that was like the dream car.
What?
That was the dream for a little while
Them Sprewells
I had to have them, them spinning wheels.
Can you remember making
any investment mistakes?
Because I think whenever you
talk to people about money,
which is so crazy,
I always ask...
I do grassroots basketball. Right?
So AAU programs.
I always pick a kid in the room and I say,
"What would you do with
a million dollars?"
And it's always the kid
who thinks that they're
giving the smart answer
and they be like, "Well,
I'm gonna invest it."
Well, you don't always
make money when you invest.
Have you ever had any
situations where you're like,
"Man, I wish I wouldn't have did that."
But you learned from it.
Right.
I haven't had any big,
massive mistakes yet
in terms of losses, like of money.
I mean, I'm always gonna invest an amount
that if it went to zero
immediately I'd be safe.
But the one thing that I am frustrated by
is there's this company
called Athletic Brewing.
It's a non-alcoholic brewing company.
And I had a chance to get in very early.
I'm talking very early.
And I sat there and I was talking
about non-alcoholic beer,
and I'm from Wisconsin.
Everybody in Wisconsin drinks.
Yeah, that's great.
So I'm like,
I got my buddies and I'm
bouncing the idea off them.
And they're like, "Why the
hell would anybody drink beer
with no alcohol?"
And I was like, "I don't
know but these numbers
look really good, man.
People are buying it."
But like I convinced myself not
to do it in the early round.
And a year later it was 3X, 4X.
And I got in the next round,
I always kicked myself about
not believing in myself.
That's definitely happened to me before.
Oh man.
And you just sort of gotta let it go.
And sometimes you look
at your financial advisor
and you say,
"It's your fault."
And the problem was, I had
somebody that was telling me,
"You gotta do it. You gotta do it."
And I shoved them off.
And now I have to
look them in the eyes cause
they went in on the first one
and I gotta apologize.
Be like, "You're right."
So for you over your years in the league,
you done got a ton of awards.
What do you think you're
the most proud of?
It has to be the Walter
Payton Man of the Year award
because that's the one that
hundreds of thousands of
millions of people helped me get.
It wasn't me.
It's not me. I mean,
I was the facilitator.
I started the fundraiser for Harvey
and I was the guy who coordinated it.
But it was people like you.
It was people like the
kids from Pennsylvania
that had a lemonade stand
that sent in their money to the charity.
It was people from Germany and London
and people from all over sending it.
So it wasn't me.
That's the award that feels like
the community helped me get the most.
The fact that you raised over $40 million,
how did that impact you?
How did that change you?
When I started the fundraiser,
I literally was trying to raise $100,000.
I put $100,000 of my own, and I said,
"I wanna raise $100,000 to match it."
And the first celebrity,
the first famous person,
the first person to call
me was you with a donation.
And I'll tell people
that in every interview
for the rest of my life,
that you set off the
foundation for everybody else.
And we raised over $40 million.
And it was insane.
People from all over the country,
all over the world were donating
and showing their support.
It was an experience
I will never experience again in my life.
And I hope that we
never have to go through
things like that again.
But never have I had more hope in humanity
than I had during that time.
The communities that we play in
are who support us.
So when I saw all the
work that you was doing,
I was inspired.
I'm forever grateful for
everything that you did there, man.
It was a wild time,
and it was...
Man, you don't wanna talk about hectic.
That was the most hectic
couple of months ever.
We were in the middle of training camp
and we were...
I'd have practice and
meetings during the day.
And then at night we'd
be meeting with charities
and politicians and FEMA, and Red Cross.
And we're trying to figure out...
Figure out where to go.
Figure out exactly how to do it
and to make sure that you're
doing it properly, man.
It was a wild time.
It's something I hope I never
have to go through again.
But I also learned so much from it.
And we helped so many people
because of the generosity of others.
And while everyone remembers that,
it started for you in college, right?
You started your JJ Watt Foundation
when you were in college.
Yeah.
And one of your biggest mottos is
"Dream big, work hard." right?
You believe that's what
it takes to succeed.
Yeah.
My parents taught me
from an early age to have big dreams.
They always said, "Feel free to dream big.
Feel free to think about
whatever you want to be,
but you have to be willing to work hard.
You have to be willing
to make the sacrifices
and have the discipline."
My role model for the
charity was Myron Rolle.
He was at Florida State Safety
and he started a charity
while he was in college.
And I remember watching the story on ESPN,
and they were talking
about him and his story.
And I was like, "Man, how
was he even smart enough
to know how to start a charity
while he is in college?"
So then I started researching it,
talking to law school,
and they helped me start a
charity while I was in college.
And Myron to this day
is a role model of mine.
Now he's a Rhode scholar and a doctor
and he's one of the most
brilliant people out there.
Everything. Everything.
This is super-duper than ours.
Take you down, and show you
what the court look like.
Yes.
Coolest thing about this
is having the women's team.
Yeah.
Because there's times
where we'll be in the weight room
and Skylar Diggins will
come in there lifting,
DT would be in there lifting,
you know what I mean?
Yeah, that's cool. Yeah.
I think it was after we played the Bucks.
We played somebody, and we had an off day.
And so they had just got
Tina Charles on their team,
and I came to the gym
just to come see Tina
because I knew her.
And the music was on.
Guys from my team were shooting here.
Some of the women were shooting over there
and it's just like one big family.
That's cool. Right?
Yeah.
That's special. Two badass teams too.
Right.
You was guys have been crushing it.
We might as well scrimmage, shoot.
Crushing it. Right?
That is super-duper nice
Your wife is a professional soccer player.
Yeah.
She's awesome, man.
She's incredible.
What do you think is going
to take to get female women,
professional sports,
more and more notoriety?
I think the more people talk about it,
the more people watch it,
the more people show up.
I mean, you obviously
do an unbelievable job
with showing up to the WNBA.
My wife and I will sit around
the dinner table at night,
and we'll talk about the NWSL,
and we'll talk about,
how can this be bigger?
Is there a team that we
can buy or invest in?
Is there a way that we
can influx capital into it
to make it work?
Is capital the answer?
Is there a way the viewership
needs to get better
by creating a grounds roots?
If I had the answer,
I would do it immediately.
Right, right.
But I know the conversations
are the most fun to have
because you know it's coming,
and it's just a matter of how we continue
to prop it up and build it up.
What do you think is next
as far as like investments or what not?
Like what you're gonna invest in,
but what do you think?
Yeah, I really enjoy investing.
I think it's another way to be competitive
outside of the field.
You can look through decks
and you can try and pick them apart
and try and see where the fakes are
and where the real quality things are.
And then it's also things
you're passionate about.
I have been looking at team ownership
to see if that's something
that's a possibility for me.
Not in the sense that I
just wanna slap my name
on a 1% of a team and be like,
"Hey, look at me. I'm part owner."
You wanna be involved.
I wanna be involved.
I want to be trying to
help make those decisions,
and use the athlete's perspective
to give what I think can
benefit the organization.
I think it would be really cool
if that space was in the women's space.
What year are you?
11.
12.
This is 17, right?
That's crazy.
17.
So what's crazy is, you want to love...
Especially playing for that long, and...
What? 12 is real, real long in the NFL.
So playing for this
long, you want to enjoy.
Yeah.
If I'm gonna be away from my family...
Yes. I better enjoy it.
Exactly.
Have you ever thought about...
I'm not asking you to retire,
but do you ever think about that
as far as like head injuries
and trauma and stuff like that?
Have you ever thought about like...
Yeah, I've definitely
thought about retirement.
I think I probably thought
about it too early at one point.
I started thinking about
the possibility of that when I was 26,
just because you know
you can't play forever
and you start to consider
when that day might come.
But I also on the flip side of that,
every time that it ever
creeps into my head,
I'm a competitor, man.
I'm a competitor and I wanna win.
I can see.
And I wanna leave this game
with a damn trophy. And...
I respect that.
And there's still stuff
that I feel like I'm capable
of doing and accomplishing
and being, and leading.
And I don't ever wanna look back and say,
"Man, I wish I would've."
Or, "I wish I could've."
And the injuries, and the
things that come with the game.
I've dealt with them
more than I wish I would.
Right.
But I know...
I know the consequence
and I know what the possibility is.
And I'm willing to accept
that right now to keep going.
And once that...
Once that line crosses,
and it flips to where I'm
not willing to accept it,
that'll be the day.
But right now I'm willing to
accept the pain and everything.
Try to get to glory.
I respect the hell outta that too.
I do. I do.
And it's always...
What about you?
I wanna ask you the same question.
I don't know if you're
answering it for me .
No, I will.
And it's funny.
I still love to play like
it's like my rookie year,
like when I was five years old.
And I live away from my family.
And just about every day
when I wake up and I'm not
there with my wife and my kids.
I'm like, man, is this really worth it?
Right.
And I mean,
I got friends that aren't
playing, friends that are retired,
that I talk to about it all the time.
And they always tell me,
"You know what, it's gonna
be one day when you wake up
and you really can't play.
And if you still love the game like that,
then you gotta play."
And I think my kids and my wife,
I don't think they would like
who I would be if I was home
and I can't play basketball.
I still love it too much.
Right.
Right. And if that does
change, like you said...
That's the other question though,
is that when that day does come.
You've spent 20 plus years.
Listen...
It's gonna be...
JJ, I don't care...
What's it gonna look like?
How many investments I
have or anything like that.
I'm worried about that day.
No question. I'm with you.
I'm very much worried about that day.
I'm with you.
And well, when that day's
come, I'm gonna call you.
You can call me, but we
gonna have to talk about it.
Well, we'll do something together.
Exactly.
Like golf or something.
Speaking of risk, you hosted SNL.
Yeah.
You hosted SNL.
How was that? And like,
is there any parallel
to live television in sports?
It was cool, man.
It was the best. It was a wild week.
It was a wild experience,
but it was an absolute blast.
I mean, I'm an athlete, I'm a competitor.
I go out on a field and people
cheer when I make a play.
And that's the best feeling in
sport that you can get right.
Right.
Going onto a stage like that,
staring out in an audience
and just hoping like hell
I can make them laugh, was scary.
But at the same time,
once you do get that laugh,
it's the exact same feeling
as getting a sack or scoring a touchdown.
Like there is no better feeling than that.
No redos either.
No. And it is live. And
you can't screw up, man.
And it was so many
talented people around you
and kind of, it's just like a team
cause everybody's collaborating
and everybody's trying to pull their line
off the exact right way to get that laugh
and to get that pop.
And man, it was a really cool experience
and I hope I get to do it
again because I loved it.
And I realized that like live
performing to me is a blast.
And I wish there's a way to work that in
because I've really loved it.
Well, you got a job right now
that's live every time you play.
So you stick with that for right now, man.
So I read that you a huge fan of the EPL.
Yeah, man.
English Premier League.
Yeah. I love it.
Did you want to invest in it
or something at some point? Ownership?
It would be incredible.
But man, over there,
the soccer with money,
with how it all goes by,
it's a different world over there.
You go to Chelsea, right?
Yeah, I'm a Chelsea guy.
I started in 2011.
Didier Drogba was at Chelsea,
and I started getting
to the Premier League.
I used to play with him
on Ivory Coast on FIFA,
so I was like wherever
Didier is, I'm going.
That would get you every time.
Yeah. So yeah, I'm a big Chelsea fan,
but man, it would be incredible
to invest over there,
but as such with relegation...
That's what makes it so exciting,
is that you can get relegated.
Imagine being dropped outta the NBA
if you were in the bottom three.
That, it's mind blowing.
It is. It is.
Which makes you have to be competitive.
It's unbelievable.
You have to stay competitive.
And that's what keeps it so interesting.
And I don't even think a
model like that would...
Nobody would let it happen over here,
but that's what makes it
so exciting over there.
That's super dope.
I think that's why it was always dope
in thinking about ownership
with athletes or whatnot
cause you know what it takes.
You know what I mean?
Not just from the performance
standpoint standpoint,
but you know what it's like.
The locker room needs to be like,
coaches and everything.
Right. Yeah.
You gonna be an owner someday?
I would love to.
I would love to be a governor
of one of these teams.
That's a goal of mine.
Man, I appreciate you again, man.
I appreciate you, brother .
You know it .
We'll catch up soon.
Thank you so much, JJ.
Thank you. I appreciate it.
I really appreciate it.
See you soon.